work on you
for you
the truth is everyone is going to hurt
you
you just gotta find the ones worth
suffering for
proud of how hard you are trying
Don't Look Back you are not going that
way
don't depend too much on anyone in this
world
because even your own shadow leaves you
when you are in darkness
work at your job and make a living
work on yourself and make a fortune
at your lowest you realize a lot
remember some of the best times of your
life haven't even happened yet
[Music]
this is your world
shape it or someone else will
bad habits are like a comfortable bed
easy to get into
but hard to get out of
no one is too busy it's only a matter of
priorities
if it keeps you happy
keep it quiet
the best thing I ever did was stop
telling people what's going on in my
life
striving for Success without hard work
is like trying to harvest where you
haven't planted
never Force don't beg and don't chase
someday when things are okay
you'll look back and feel proud that you
didn't give up
forgive your old self
you've changed
if you don't let go of the wrong people
you'll never meet the right people
God knows when to send you exactly what
you need
no regrets
just do better next time
there will always be someone who doesn't
see your worth
don't let it be you
seek respect not attention
it lasts longer
be careful who you trust
salt and sugar look the same
remember
some things have to end for better
things to begin
time always exposes what you truly mean
to someone
[Music]
life will separate you from your friends
so appreciate each moment you have
together
being private staying low-key
and not telling everyone everything is
self-care
money is a tool
not the goal
freedom is the goal
you are responsible for your own
happiness
if you expect others to make you happy
you will always be disappointed
do what no one else can do
and you will become what no one else can
become
stay calm you've been through this
before
you'll get through it again
a negative mind will never give you a
positive life
if people treat you like an option
leave them like a choice
value experience over possessions
because memories
are the real Treasures of life
accept what is let go of what was
have faith in what will be
so many people love you
don't focus on the people who don't
you deserve it the career the love
the family
the peace the life
your vision will be blurry
but it will grow clear with time
[Music]
patience is your ally
never forget who helped you in a
difficult time
you alone are enough
you have nothing to prove to anyone
no matter how hard the past
you can always begin again
sometimes you have to go through the
worst
to get the best
be alone until you're valued
take care of your body
remember health is another form of
wealth
if you can make a girl laugh
you can make her do anything
hard times will always reveal true
friends
better days are coming
you won't always wake up in the morning
with a heavy heart
your strongest muscle and worst enemy is
your mind
train it well
don't react
cut them off silently
someone else's progress doesn't make
yours any less
don't ever let the same people
disappoint you twice
small circle
private life
and peaceful mind
sometimes we create our own heart breaks
through expectation
it's okay to make mistakes
mistakes mean you're trying
use things
not people love people not things
even the smallest lie
can break the biggest Trust
be kind and generous without expecting
anything in return
Embrace Solitude as a time for
reflection and self-discovery
not everyone you trust will be
trustworthy
don't be afraid to express vulnerability
it shows strength
learn to handle rejection gracefully
it's a part of life
breathe
it's just a bad day not a bad life
things will get better
just wait
we have four problems overthink over
trust over share
over love
you will be disappointed in a
heartbroken multiple times
but it's how you respond that matters
don't let anyone ever make you feel like
you don't deserve what you want
we've got to do what's right for you
even if it hurts some people you love
the days that break you are the days
that make you
make more moves
and less announcements
time never Waits it only urges you to
catch up or get left behind
no relationship is worth damaging your
mental health
depend on yourself
never on others
being too nice breaks you
trust yourself
you've survived a lot and you'll survive
whatever is coming
you grow mentally weak when your life is
too comfortable
sometimes loneliness
is the price you pay for growth
you
are who you are
nobody's approval is needed
learn from what people do not from what
they tell you
expect nothing
and you will never get disappointed
Embrace every opportunity for regrets
come from the chances we didn't take
If You Can Dream It
you can do it
stop telling people more than they need
to know
you meet every single person for a
reason
just let it be
if it's meant to be it will happen
your past was never a mistake if you
learned from it
once you feel free
someone avoids you
never disturb them again
people will forget what you said
people will forget what you did
but people will never forget how you
made them feel
some things are meant to cross your way
but are not meant to stay
[Music]
your direction is more important than
your speed
never fall in love with the same person
twice because the second time you fall
in love with the memories not the person
perceived failure as a vulnerable
teacher
and a stepping stone to success
celebrate small victories and Milestones
because they paved the way for bigger
achievements
whoever brings you the most peace
should get the most time
never be afraid to treat people the way
they treat you
just be real it saves everyone's time
never think twice about investments in
yourself
they paid dividends for a long time
you need to stop the habit of doubting
yourself
you can tell more about a person by what
he says about others than you can by
what others say about him
don't share your personal life with
anyone
do not let anyone have anything that
could harm you
your heart will tell you where to go
your head will guide you there safely
use one without the other and you'll get
lost
hard work doesn't always pay off
learn to stop in time and understand
whether you have turned into a Slave
[Music]
life will only come around once so do
whatever makes you happy
can't do big things
you are distracted by small things
remember
five years ago you dreamed about being
where you are now
think about it